have you ever wondered what it would be
like to see cloud strife from final
fantasy 7 beat the [ __ ] out of Sonic the
Hedgehog guess what super smash brothers
fans fan favorite cloud strife of final
fantasy 7 fame is making his way into
Nintendo's brawler holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
earlier this year Nintendo polls fans
online what characters they most wanted
to see in the new super smash brothers
and it looks like the votes are in cloud
strife of final fantasy 7 fame is the
game's latest confirmed fighter oh my
genova during a Nintendo Direct
presentation today Nintendo not only
revealed the spiky-haired buster sword
wielder but they also showed off his
moves Limit Breaks anyone and a new
stage based on Final Fantasy 7 city of
Midgar cloud will come with different
costumes that reflect character design
changes through both the game and the
movies including that weird advent
children get up however it's not clear
if there will be a design based on his
blocky original ps1 appearance the
Midgar stage that comes with cloud
features a massive mako reactor in the
background and similar to smashes
pokemon stages this one will feature
cameos from final fantasy 7 summons that
will wreak havoc on players holy [ __ ]
the announcement is notable because it
also means that eventually you guessed
it Nintendo will be making a cloud
strife amiibo in addition new final
fantasy themed costumes modeled after
chocobos are coming to the game the last
character revealed for Super Smash
Brothers was Ryu from Street Fighter
another longtime crossover favorite
while today's Nintendo Direct only
featured some new info you will be able
to get an even deeper dive next month
the next Super Smash Brothers focus
direct is scheduled for December for
more news on final fantasy 7 that is not
the Final Fantasy 7 remake tune in to
gamespot com